[Música]
los ministros de energía de la unión
europea aprobaron un borrador para
recortar su demanda de gas en un 15 por
ciento y hasta marzo de 2023 la medida
llega a horas de la entrada en vigor de
una reducción en el suministro de este
hidrocarburo por parte de la rusa
gazprom
de visita en cameros del presidente de
francia emmanuel macro un cargo contra
rusia por su papel en la crisis
alimentaria obstaculizando exportaciones
de granos y fertilizantes tras su
invasión a ucrania
se cumplen 70 años de la muerte de eva
duarte de perón figura icónica de la
historia argentina decenas de personas
le rinden tributo en su mausoleo en
buenos aires en esta emisión tenemos
análisis de su legado
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de france 24 gracias por continuar con
nosotros yo soy juan pupiales ante el
inminente comienzo de un recorte en el
suministro de la estatal rusa gazprom
los ministros de energía de la unión
europea aprobaron un borrador de
propuesta para reducir en un 15% su
demanda entre agosto y marzo próximos de
gas la unión busca así hacer frente a de
la escases del hidrocarburo desde este
miércoles el flujo de gas precisamente a
través del gasoducto nord stream 1 entre
rusia y alemania- estará trabajando a
una quinta parte de su capacidad aunque
la medida de hoy busca entregar un
mensaje de unidad ya algunos gobiernos
como el de hungría la calificaron como
injustificada o inútil desde españa
piden que este requerimiento se acomode
a las posibilidades de cada país
en este escenario naciones como alemania
uno de los motores de la unión defienden
el actuar conjunto de los 27 estados
miembros
hemos visto muy claramente en las
últimas semanas y meses que la
estrategia es mantener el precio alto en
europa y por lo tanto hacer que el
precio político sea cada vez más /
europa y así también romper con
solidaridad hacia ucrania este consejo
el día de hoy con su decisión ha enviado
una señal fuerte y decidida en contra de
eso y creo que esto también se escuchará
en moscú europa no se puede dividir los
músicos con varias naciones del
continente africano están experimentando
problemas en su suministro de
alimentación en medio del bloqueo de las
exportaciones de grano en el mar negro
en este contexto el canciller ruso
sérguei lávrov visitó al presidente
ugandés yoweri museveni en la ciudad de
entebbe lávrov afirmó que la crisis
alimentaria no tiene relación con la
denominada operación militar que
adelantan en ucrania
uganda es un importante socio de moscú
ya en marzo se abstuvo de votar en una
resolución de naciones unidas que
condenó la invasión de moscú sobre el
territorio ucraniano
hemos discutido la situación actual en
el mercado de energía y el suministro de
alimentos y lo que nuestros amigos
africanos deben entender es que la
situación actual no tiene nada que ver
con la operación militar especial en
ucrania
acordamos que en nuestras relaciones
bilaterales nos vamos a basar en estos
principios y vamos a buscar nuevas áreas
o nuevas formas de cooperación en el
mercado de la energía y los alimentos
mientras tanto el presidente de francia
emmanuel macrón en visita en camerún
denunció lo que definió como hipocresía
con el continente africano a la hora de
no reconocer el papel de russián en la
crisis alimentaria actual como una
agresión unilateral macrón hizo un
llamado a incentivar la producción en
este continente el mandatario estuvo
acompañado por su homólogo camerunés
paul biyá y también expuso las
dificultades por las que pasa su
economía
[Música]
la crisis que estamos pasando es una
oportunidad para avanzar a todos nos
atacan diciendo que las sanciones
europeas son la causa de la crisis
alimentaria son mentiras absolutas
totalmente falsas los alimentos y la
energía- se han convertido en el arma de
guerra de rusia pero todos tenemos que
enfrentar nuestras responsabilidades
debemos ayudar al continente africano a
producir más para sí mismos y la agenda
para el desarrollo agrícola sostenible y
la reforestación es clave
al menos 15 muertos y decenas de heridos
dejé el segundo día de protestas en la
república democrática del congo según
informaron las autoridades desde el
lunes decenas de personas salieron a las
calles de goma para exigir la retirada
del personal de la misión de
estabilización de las naciones unidas
conocidas como monos cómo es que los
congoleños aseguran que esta misión de
paz es ineficiente tras más de 20 años
de presencia ante un incremento de la
violencia por parte de los grupos
rebeldes que operan en el territorio
marina sardenya tiene los detalles
gases lacrimógenos y balas para reprimir
a los manifestantes en el segundo día de
protestas contra la misión de
mantenimiento de la paz de naciones
unidas monusco que deja ya varios
muertos y decenas de heridos según las
autoridades congoleñas la situación
actual en kivú del norte nos preocupa
entendemos el hartazgo de la población
víctima de tantos ataques pero los
invitamos a manifestarse pacíficamente
los gobernantes de facto y el consejo de
seguridad deben asumir sus
responsabilidades pese a que el alcalde
prohibió las protestas la población
salió a las calles bloqueando algunas
vías y asaltaron las instalaciones de la
monusco exigen la salida del país del
organismo al que acusan de ineficiencia
frente a la inseguridad endémica que
vive la nación africana y es que al
menos 122 grupos armados ilegales operan
en el territorio congoleño la bomba está
máxima entonces están lanzando gases
lacrimógenos porque hemos venido a decir
que la monusco no nos ayuda llevamos 22
años en el congo y nada funciona hemos
venido a exigir nuestros derechos pero
nos disparan con gases lacrimógenos
pida matrimonio futurmoda lo que acaba
de suceder aquí un soldado de paz ha
matado a una persona aquí en su base y
ha herido a otra ya no los queremos aquí
que se vayan a sus casas no valen el
bato con ortiz buback va en el juego por
su parte la misión de paz emitió un
comunicado considerando los altercados
de inaceptables a la vez que evacuaba a
algunos de sus integrantes
los incidentes de goma no sólo son
inaceptables sino totalmente
contraproducentes la monusco tiene el
mandato del consejo de seguridad para
acompañar a las autoridades en la
protección de los civiles las protestas
se producen al tiempo que se
intensifican los combates entre el
ejército congolés y el principal grupo
rebelde el m23 que ha obligado a más de
200.000 personas a huir de sus hogares
japón ejecutó este martes el autor de la
conocida como masacre de akihabara este
crimen cometido en 2008 dejó 7 muertos y
10 heridos el autor de los hechos
embistió con su auto a una multitud y
luego atacó a otros transeúntes con arma
blanca
perotti se expone la realidad de la
aplicación de la pena de muerte en
democracias consolidadas en occidente
para analizar este tema hablamos con
antonio muñoz doctor en derecho y
fundador de la red académica
internacional por la abolición de la
pena capital señor muñoz gracias por
estar con nosotros según datos de
amnistía internacional dos tercios de
los países del planeta han abolido de la
pena capital pero como vemos hay
naciones democráticas como japón corea
del sur o incluso eeuu que continúan
aplicando este castigo cuál es la
situación a nivel internacional de la
pena de muerte
viene la pena de muerte está en remisión
y desgraciadamente en estas últimas
semanas hemos tenido un repunte y pero
también tenemos que decir que realmente
cuando hablamos de solamente son dos
democracias las que aplican la pena de
muerte pero realmente en eeuu no podemos
hablar de una aplicación generalizada
realmente son muy pocos los estados que
mantienen una pena capital y en los
estados que mantienen la pena capital
son muy pocos las ejecuciones que se
producen
en japón bueno realmente en japón es un
país que
curiosamente mantiene su pena capital
desde hace mucho tiempo
dentro de las categorizaciones en
materia de mantenimiento de la pena
capital tenemos los países
abolicionistas exactos de iure los
países retencionistas
y hay países que realmente aplican la
pena de muerte pero muy
puntualmente lo cual es un sinónimo de
crueldad porque realmente no es eficaz
no es disuasoria y además atenta contra
la dignidad humana en este caso hacía
unos meses que japón había afectado a
33 ciudadanos de su país pero realmente
vemos que la situación es bastante
favorable porque la mayoría de los
países hoy día son hablar de un más de
130 países que son abolicionistas y
además en la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas cada cierto tiempo se
adopta una resolución
se pide la no aplicación de la pena de
capital para aquellos países que tengan
a través de una moratoria la moratoria
se ha considerado que es un instrumento
muy útil para acabar alcanzar la
abolición de la pena señor muñoz es
precisamente hablando de algo que usted
ya comentaba sirve la pena de muerte a
la hora de combatir la criminalidad o
transmitir un mensaje de por decirlo
justicia frente a crímenes como el
terrorismo
no ha habido muchos estudios esto ya se
produjo en el reino unido los años 50
cuando se llegó a una una se hizo un
análisis durante mucho tiempo para ver
si durante la moratoria es el importante
instrumento si durante la moratoria
había ascendido el número de crímenes y
se constató que el número de crímenes
había incluso
se había reducido y en materia de
terrorismo
entendemos que primero la pena de muerte
es cruel y el estado no puede luchar
contra el terrorismo con los mismos
mecanismos que aplican los terroristas
durante la aplicación de la pena de
muerte tenemos países capitán la pena de
muerte en tiempos de guerra y también
nosotros consideramos que esa aplicación
debe de ser reducida y por qué porque
incluso si fuese eficaz que no lo es
estamos ante una situación de crueldad
de atentado no solamente contra la vida
del contra el ser humano sino también
contra contra la dignidad humana de
hecho en japón se produce además una
situación muy muy peculiar el ejecutado
no sabe que va a ser ejecutado
en las 24 horas previas a la ejecución
lo cual no lo sabe tampoco su familia lo
cual es una señal de que hay un cura
y por lo tanto dime si señor antonio
muñoz y nos acabó el tiempo muchas
gracias por su análisis aquí en france
24 cambiamos de tema hablamos de la
región
el presidente peruano pedro castillo
debe acudir en menos de 48 horas al
parlamento a exponer un balance tras su
primer año de gestión con 74 por ciento
de desaprobación según las encuestas el
panorama político se complica para el
mandatario pues su antigua mano derecha
bruno pacheco quien se encontraba
prófugo se entregó a la justicia desde
el imán nuestro corresponsal francisco
zacarías los entregó previamente el
siguiente informe
bruno pacheco ex secretario presidencial
de pedro castillo se entregó a la
justicia peruana tras largas
negociaciones con el ministerio público
la fiscal general de perú patricia
benavides confirmó el hecho señaló que
no hay intocables y que nadie pedirá
enfrentar a los poderosos porque los
peruanos merecen un país libre de
corruptos bruno pacheco llevaba casi
cuatro meses en la clandestinidad y hoy
se ha convertido en testigo protegido de
la justicia su condición actual puede
perjudicar al estatus legal del
presidente pedro casi o porque pacheco a
cambio en ir a prisión va a otorgar
pruebas a la fiscalía que viene
investigando al mandatario por los
presuntos delitos de corrupción tráfico
de influencias peculado y obstrucción a
la justicia se espera que una vez la
fiscal general de perú consiga armar el
caso se dirige al parlamento a fin de
sostener una eventual acusación
constitucional contra pedro casi o que
podrían incluir el retiro de su
inmunidad presidencial y la solicitud de
una prisión preventiva contra él si este
proceso se viabiliza tiene baluarte la
vicepresidenta estaría habilitada para
continuar la línea de sucesión y acceder
al poder pero existen dos denuncias
contra el baluarte en el parlamento que
pretenden inhábil carla por
irregularidades que habría cometido
siendo funcionaria pública algunos
congresistas han afirmado que iniciarán
un proceso de destitución en su contra
es por eso que cobra relevancia a la
elección de la nueva mesa directiva del
parlamento los legisladores están
eligiendo no sólo a la nueva jefa o jefe
del congreso sino también a la persona
que regiría el destino de millones de
peruanos porque si pedro casi o es
destituido del cargo y en caso de no
evaluar que sea inhabilitada la sucesión
recaerá en quien ejerza la presidencia
del congreso se cumplen 70 años de la
muerte de eva duarte de perón una de las
figuras clave en la historia argentina
con fotografías y flores blancas a
cientos de personas se reunieron en el
cementerio de la recoleta en buenos
aires para rendir homenaje a evita quien
murió el 26 de julio de 1952 con 33 años
siete décadas después de su muerte la
figura de eva sigue viva en la política
argentina con un legado que incluye el
derecho de las mujeres a votar y
beneficios para las clases trabajadoras
para desarrollar ese tema en profundidad
hablamos previamente con santiago regolo
historiador que hace parte del área de
investigación del museo evita quien nos
explicó como ella sigue como a grupos
jóvenes y sobre todo a mujeres
sí bueno la juventud es hoy por hoy se
están acercando muchísimo al legado de
eba y fundamentalmente mujeres en estos
nuevos contextos donde la presencia
femenina es muy importante donde se
empiezan a rediscutir ciertas cuestiones
atravesadas por perspectivas de género
de igualdad en términos también de
género es más fue muy pero muy
importante por eso ha convocado a
muchísima gente valor historia pero
fundamentalmente ahora y estas mujeres
que ven se ven reflejadas en eba que
también ella actuó en un momento donde
la presencia política en espacio de
poder a las mujeres era muy resistida
ellas sin ningún tipo de cargo se ha
transformado en una lideresa
impresionante y al día de hoy ese
reflejo ese evento a esas mujeres que se
ven convocadas en todo el trabajo que
hizo para y en favor de las mujeres en
términos políticos en términos sociales
y en términos de reivindicaciones muy
fuertes en marcos de igualdad terminamos
así esta emisión informativa la
información continúa en esta pantalla
también en nuestro sitio web france24
puntocom
[Música]